those people in the youtube comments that read the chromium source code
they the real mvps man like that's the real yeah just leaving that in a youtube
comment instead of like tweeting it or something dude it's got one like you know it's crazy
yo yo yo how's it going dude you look like you just got hit by a train dude i'm so tired
for context yeah for i'll give a little context here i did two live hacking that's back to back
uh one week and then the other week so two weeks ago i was in london with you we did uh the hacker
one live hacking event yeah talk cosmon then yeah i went right from there i flew to seoul south korea
oh my god and i was there for another week and i did uh a meta live hacking event um and i
participated with nagly former uh podcast guest and uh you know we found some really cool bugs on there
and uh then yesterday i flew home so i am like my body is screaming at me about time zones and all that
stuff uh seoul is 16 hours ahead of here and london is eight hours ahead of here so it was just from
like one eight hour time difference into another eight hour time difference and then back to my normal
time so i am uh i'm i'm like half asleep right now so you'll have to forgive uh any latency that i've got
in my brain yeah no worries man i'm sorry i picked such a tricky episode to prep for uh for when you
come back but yeah i haven't i haven't seen you this tired looking in a long time um but yeah i mean i
was i was gonna ask you because we haven't really had the chance to catch up either how was the how was
the meta event dude yeah the meta event was really cool uh we found a zero day i think that's all i can
say we found a zero day in an open source piece of software um and it ended up in an xss i think
that's that's about as much as that's that's big on facebook man they pay big for those yeah yeah it
was a pretty cool pretty cool bug uh i was actually very surprised that we were able to find it uh a lot
of the people that i talked to there who are like big time facebook hackers were also quite surprised they
said that the nexus has on facebook especially facebook core is something that really yeah uh it's like a
once a year type of thing it really almost never happens so i was i was pretty stoked that we found
that and that it worked and then it popped and all that yeah you guys popped it pretty quick too i
think i saw like the i think i saw noggly flexing in a hacker chat like like two or three days into the
event and i was like oh yeah yeah yeah so shout out to space raccoons basically we also collabed with
that event and space raccoon had explored a very similar bug uh probably within the last year um he he
exploited a very very similar bug to this and so when we added him to the group we were just talking
about like the leads and stuff that we were looking at and all that kind of stuff and i mentioned i was
like yeah we have this uh we have this potential like zero day but i've been looking at it i haven't
really uh gone into like the full details on how to exploit it and he was like oh i'm pretty sure
i know how to exploit this and in like an hour he popped it and i was like ah that's amazing so that's
like the whole like i mean that's like a perfect example of collaboration and how like you can merge
like past experience together by like working with other hackers because i i'm sure we could have
exploited it but it would have taken us significantly more time and you know it was just so much easier
to bring somebody in who knew what they were doing and yeah for sure and space raccoon is also a uh
previous podcast guest he was i think i think he was the first guest we had on the i believe he was
yeah yeah so definitely we'll we'll link those episodes down in the description um both nogli and
space raccoon mega good supreme hackers yeah yeah how is how are the vibes like you know we've done a lot
of hacker one live hacking events together you know and i feel like hacker one's got it down pat pretty
well now but how are the meta live hacking event vibes yeah so i think it's important to remember that meta
run well meta runs their own bug bounty program yeah and meta also isn't a bug bounty company so for
hacker one the live hacking events are both a marketing opportunity as well as something that is core to
their brand right for meta it's a security event you know what i mean it's like a meetup so for meta you
know the the swag and stuff is significantly like less over the top like all the ceremonial stuff is
significantly less over the top and all that kind of stuff because all they really care about is like
finding cool bugs paying for those bugs and having people on site and like showing them a good time
and for hacker one it's like how do we make this like amazing hacking event experience right and so
like i think it's two two very different things but overall like the core of the event in terms
of like having hackers on site being able to like talk with all these like amazing people i got to
talk with um like yusuf who's like an amazing facebook hacker he focuses only on on meta and that kind
of stuff and a lot of the people there who are people who like dedicate all their time to hacking on
meta which is something that i barely spend any time hacking on so it was like a very interesting like
perspective shift to get to talk to those people and see like how they approach a platform like meta and
the types of stuff that they find and all that kind of stuff and it was really really impressive to
see that the bugs that people will find so nice dude wow not gonna lie man not gonna lie i'm a little
jealous it sounded like an awesome event i um i had a bachelor party that weekend which was also
awesome but you know south korea live hacking event sounds pretty freaking lit man yeah seoul is a very
cool place i'd never been to south korea so that was a lot of time there too right yeah yeah we took uh
we did a day or two ahead and a day or two after as well just to like get to see sites and explore and go
shopping and experience the the country in the city so yeah i definitely would recommend going to south
korea it's it's an amazing place and you should experience it for yourself nice man well joel you're
you're six minutes in you're still alive so i am hopefully you won't fall asleep as we talk about
all the mega technical stuff we're going to talk about today because unlike some of the past episodes
that we've had um this one is going to be like pretty in the freaking weeds so um yeah yeah i was
just mentioning i i sent you a message like five minutes before we started that this whole episode
could be a news episode because of the amount of like news and links and new very relevant stuff
that's happened in the last like week or two um around this topic being you know like browser quirks
and behaviors and yeah restrictions and that kind of stuff yeah yeah there's been a bunch and uh and
yeah i i i messaged joel and i was like hey man you might want to like you know allocate a little
extra prep time for this episode and i'm sure he was like you know laying in bed trying to get every
last little bit of sleep but i was like literally adding stuff to this episode up until the last
minute so sorry if you didn't get the chance to review all of it i i you know there's some grace
i know you're coming right back from the from the life hacking event so um yeah i guess we'll just kind
of hop into it um the first one that i wanted to talk about i don't know if you saw this one but
um it's titled hunting so new stuff right this is uh hunting for nginx alias traversals in the wild
this was released just yesterday um by i don't know how to print like i want to pronounce this hawkeye labs
but i'm not sure if that's exactly how you pronounce it um but dude this is just such a beautiful example
of like taking research and then applying it and just popping crazy bugs right like this this research
has been out here this nginx um research was released by orange in black hat 2018 this is five
year old research right and then you know if you read through the blog post homie's just like
okay well let's apply this so he goes to github search and just writes a regex and then pops like multiple
bounties with it and i'm just like what a g yeah yeah so i was talking with with nagli a lot we were
hanging a lot out a lot well on the on this whole trip and i think this is like a perfect use case for
nuclei right where yeah like this is probably something that doesn't exist in a rule already
maybe it does right but i mean if it did it probably would have been found by more things yeah but
if you see research like this like some like if you were to have noticed like orange's blog post back
in 2018 or their presentation back in 2018 yeah that would be a great use case for something that you
can get an advantage on or an edge against everybody else by turning that into a query putting it into
your own nuclei setup and then running it across all the targets that you're monitoring and then using
that to your advantage as sort of you know nobody like it's out there but it's not out there you know
what i mean yeah no for sure and and i i i think that's true and i think there's i i've actually
personally done some scanning for this for this exact vulnerability um but i think what's really
interesting about the way that this guy you know applied it was he you know went after open source
stuff with this um which i think is really smart because by nature of this um and i know we we actually
haven't said which which research we're talking about this is the uh uh off by off by a slash research um
by uh by orange in 2018 so essentially if you have a nginx location defined and the location does not
have a slash at the end and then the alias that it's pointing to or the or the um i think there's one other
one well yeah if the alias that it's pointing to does not have a slash at the end um you can actually
it can actually result in a path traversal i think it's the other way actually it has so
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so the location doesn't have a slash but the alias does have a slash and then
that makes it vulnerable the location does have
wait hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on so so it says for the technique to be applicable the
following conditions must be met the location directive should not have a trailing slash in
its path and an alias directive must be present with the location context and it must end with a
slash right right because that slash is what's getting passed through right okay gotcha okay yeah so um
and then thanks for clearing that up man i love how like your brain operating at 50 still like you
know no um that's at least i can still read yeah i've got that going for me you got you got that one
on me joel um no yeah so uh and and like i said before i'd actually played around with this specific
phone and i wrote my own sort of um nuclei module for this it's not nuclei it was my own custom thing
but um i think the open source approach is really really smart because um by nature of this vulnerability
you only have one path to result right you only get to go up one directory level and so you kind
of got to know what is in that directory in order to be able to fully exploit this vulnerability and
so um in the in the in the blog post he talks about um exploiting this against bitwarden uh self-hosted
bitwarden and uh and it resulting in the database um being leaked uh which is like a big l yeah yeah
bitwarden's a password manager right yeah yeah so that's that's great and he said that they they um
fix the issue and give it the max bounty for their broke bounty program so love to see that and then i think
they also found something similar on google um seems like that one got a little bit less rewarded but um
it it definitely seems like yeah it's only 500 bucks for that it seems like that should have a bit more
but maybe there were some mitigating factors but yeah yeah i'm sure that that there were i feel like
i and this is a little little bit of a tangent but having looked at like the facebook and microsoft and
google programs a little bit now yeah it's really crazy how much money they pay i mean we're talking
like for perspective here zoom probably the second most high paying program would be my guess on hacker one
public program they paid i think like seven or eight million total number one i think they paid 14
12 or 14 million google and facebook and microsoft i believe all paid at least one million dollars last year alone
wow dang dude and that's without running live events wow that's some serious that's some serious output
yeah it's i mean it's it's kind of crazy um and i think part of that is that like some of the bugs
they pay for are very very high bugs so i know like google had this one bug that they paid like
over a half a million for it was like a really bad pixel bug um wow and like you know some of the
hackers at the facebook event for example like yusuf he walked away with like a couple hundred k by
himself so he posted about that on twitter yeah yeah so like definitely there are some like high earners
and stuff and some some categories but i think it's important to realize that even like some of the
the largest programs on hacker one are kind of dwarfed by these mega companies who are doing their own
programs and uh yeah i mean it's it's really wild like generally speaking like if they're paying low
it's because they it's like there's some like crazy crazy confounding factor because they're pretty
they're pretty liquid and they like to pay bounties pretty pretty liquid i like yeah i always i look for
the programs that are really liquid if you know what i'm talking about yeah yeah yeah so um but yeah i
just wanted to highlight this one because i thought this was a really cool application and just encouraging
that like you can go find old research that you know has been around for a while and you know go and
apply it write your own tool write your own way to look to come up with your own way to look for it
and uh it'll it could result in some really cool bugs yeah well and i also like that uh in this blog
like the first thing that they tried was just using a github code search which is a super accessible way
to search for stuff because it's open it's free it's available you just literally go to cs.gethub.com
and yeah you know go ahead and and search for your regex that's going to find the vulnerabilities and
make you money right out of the bat but you don't even have to spin up a special tool or anything like
that so and does code search i know that they just pushed this out not too long ago i can't guess i can't
say just recently does it have 100 indexing now or no that i'm not sure about i know that it was
limited in the beginning yeah i think they probably expanded it all the way now yeah but source graph
which is like probably the the main competitor or i guess code search is probably the competitor to
source graph because source graphic kit was there first but source graph you could always spin up your
own source graph instance as well and then you can tell it to index you know a bunch of repos or you can
tell it to index like i don't think you can have it indexed like all of github yeah that would be
pretty intense yeah but if you have like a list of organizations right so if you take a list of
public bug bounty programs go get their github organization names put them in a list index all of
their repos that would probably be a good strategy yeah no totally agree there um next on the list is
this another banger from port swigger research i have to say i really appreciate that account man like
that's they've really put out some good stuff um and this the tweet that i'm talking about is the one
regarding um popovers uh which is a new feature in chrome and you know just as they as chrome releases
it port swigger research finds a way to pop something with it um and essentially there's a new way to
trigger xss on uh any any um i think it's any element yeah any tag yeah that's i was trying to come up
with arbitrary yeah or any it doesn't even have to be an element right it's just any tag yeah yeah so um
that's really cool to see um and then it was also really cool to see the surrounding research on that
too that kind of everyone like cure53 commented on it um i don't know how to pronounce this guy's name
or still or still commented on it with some really sort of yeah uh sort of brain boggling stuff um so yeah
that's definitely a cool technique to be on the lookout for i'm not sure how often like this will be
useful as opposed to a different xss vector um maybe like helpful for bypassing some wafts and stuff like
that but um still something cool to be aware of nonetheless yeah so i when i was looking at it i think
it it's like at minimum one click right there are two clicks yeah one click so there's definitely some
some confounding factors here that it's going to lower the impact a little bit depending on how
the company looks at it like some companies might just say any xss is valuable to us even if it's two
click maybe you can also craft a poc that would make it plausible kind of like a click jacking type of
thing where you can you know create a scenario that would make sense for the user to be clicking twice or
something like that um but even still i i think like over the last couple months we've seen a lot
of things get removed from chrome and a lot of uh changes that have made things more secure and it's
been almost almost disheartening as a bug bounty hunter to see that all these xss vectors disappear
and uh they're looking out for us they're they're adding new xss vectors for us it's nice thank you
the heart doesn't it just yeah the internet's becoming more vulnerable just what i thought that
i was gonna have to stop filing these bugs now there are new methods here we go yeah yeah so um and i
think it's also really cool that it triggers it's sort of a multi-element sort of thing right because
there's like the button that you click on and then there's this custom attribute pop over target
and then you provide the id for a different element and then it triggers something on that element and
as cure 53 pointed out that element can even be hidden or um disabled disabled yeah yeah which i think
is is really cool as well because there are some fringe circumstances and you we really get down in the
weeds um you know with some of these technicalities sometimes but when you have all these things floating
around in your head as you see these scenarios pop up uh over time when you're hunting um it's really it's
really great when you can use some really fringe research to pop a bug um and that's how you avoid
dupes as well because not a lot of people are on top of this stuff yeah you know the first thing that
popped into my mind about the hidden value thing is a pattern that i see a lot in what in web which is
that there'll be either like a state or maybe a token or something in the url parameters and that'll get
reflected into an html form yeah for like submission like it'll be like a token and then you'll click a button in
the page and it'll submit that value again yeah and i think if you could find obviously you need kind
of a second injection point to make it so that you can trigger the the popover target but if you can
inject this even into a hidden form element right then you can take advantage of that excess yeah yeah
for sure and that's a good that's a good excess tip in general is that and you can even work backwards
from it right like if you're trying to figure out what query parameters could go into uh you know could
be used in this specific page you can go into the source look at the hidden input parameters right
and and see what the name or id of those are and then try those in the url um and that may allow
you to set some malicious defaults um by a url parameter if it's reflected down in there or um might
even allow you to get xss so yeah yeah for sure so definitely check out like the quote tweets and
stuff on that port swigger research and yeah also just set your tweet alerts up for port swigger
research because i don't think there's ever been a tweet that they've made that's been like ah this
is not a good tweet but like i feel like every time every single thing that they push out is is very
like high quality research just generally speaking we've also talked about the port swigger web academy
stuff which is also really high quality yeah it's always like very on the front edge of like what's
actually exploitable and all that kind of stuff and and good for for training and getting new people
like accustomed to exploiting xss and other web web vulnerabilities so definitely go check that that
out check out their account and their website for sure um okay so before we move on from this section
check out the tweet by sarush um urstle this is yep this is really this is really interesting to me i was like
kind of looking at this for a while before i could figure out what the heck was going on here
and it this is not even really like anything crazy to do with the pop over target thing the thing
that's really crazy for me with this is that he uses two equal signs after pop over target right so the
the the code we're talking about here is is button space pop over target equals equals and then it's a
double quote right so he's defining an attribute but this attribute is not using the double quote as the
beginning of the attribute like you would normally see in html it's actually using two equal signs so
the first equal sign defines the attribute and the second equal sign is just a content of the attribute
right yeah and then that inside of that content of the attribute is a double quote right yeah i think
this is really really nifty and i think you can use this in a bunch of different situations for waft bypasses
or xss filter bypasses because um i imagine that there will be a regex that is looking specifically
when it's parsing html attributes looking specifically for that for that um for that
equal sign and then double quote right so if you have two equal signs that might
continue the regex and it will assume that the double quote is the beginning of the attribute but
actually the the second equal sign is the beginning of the attribute which i think i think that was
really cool i hadn't seen that technique before yeah i didn't i didn't really realize like this was
possible and it yeah reading it it's very confusing to understand like what's actually going on here
i am i correct that it's using the equals as the val like the value of the attribute so like basically
your popover target is something that's called like equals yeah yeah it looks like it yeah and so you see
look at the id down there it's a so if you look at input right the input tag the id for that is equals
equals equals equals you know uh less than bang dash dash right and that matches the popover target from
above which looks like an html comment to a parser but actually this is this is just a part of the
the attribute because of the way it's set up so really really cool um stuff there and i think
cross-applicable in a lot of other xss scenarios yeah i have a feeling this will probably come up with
uh some some like third-party xs or html parsers and stuff that are going to be checking for xss by
parsing the html elements just like you said and uh we'll be handling that incorrectly because it's going
to look like an html comment in there or something like that or might not one-to-one meet the spec
and they might just like have like a one character slip up and that's all it takes yeah for sure so
definitely this one's a little bit easier to to see than to hear about so definitely check out this
one we'll link it in the description yeah um all right so speaking of cool xss stuff um we have another
one here which was kind of surprising to me um uh the rce man ironically client side bug um uh tweeted
this out and he said don't forget about the magical math element which can make any html element clickable
within the firefox browser and so he defines a math element and then inside of that defines an xss tag
just a you know less than xss space you know defines that tag and and uh sets the href to that
to a javascript href and you click on that and it triggers in uh in firefox which and i tried to figure
out why this is like what is it about the math tag that makes it makes everything clickable and i couldn't
figure it out so it it seems like this is just one of those weird quirks it might help to know in some
fringe circumstances yeah it's it's super super weird um and i will add a little caveat here um
firefox i think like in tech a lot of people use firefox and like it's it's an easy misconception to
think that firefox is probably one of the largest browsers out there however if you look up the browser
market share stats the top right hold on hold on hold on let me guess i want to say it's like i want
to say it's around 12 12 firefox yeah i i don't know not even close what really not even close yeah not
even close okay so it's like 60 chrome right 20 to 25 safari and firefox is at about two and a half percent
no way really it's yeah it's underneath edge right so like out of the box yeah oh my god under edge so
like the reality is that like the majority of people who are using a computer are using the built-in
browser or or chrome just because of its dominance in the market so like chrome obviously number one by a
long shot but then it's safari and edge as the two next browsers because those are the ones that are built
into mac and windows wow dude that is definitely surprising to me and i will say though um i feel
like edge is going to gain some popularity back because you can only use bing like search ai stuff
in edge i tried to do it in chrome the other day and it was like no no no no no go to edge and i'm like
true what is wrong with you i launched edge like for the first time in probably five years because i wanted
to use the bing ai to search for something exactly man so i don't know i i you know microsoft is really
leaning into trying to claw back some of that you know browser real estate um but i don't know and this
may i mean i wouldn't be surprised if this pulled a percent or two away from them and at the end of the
day it is using chromium you know as a base now so you know may not be too bad who knows yeah it might
not be too bad i think like the biggest thing is just like how integrated chrome is with yeah your
accounts and just extensions and all that kind of stuff yeah yeah for sure man um dude we just have
so much xss stuff today so many weird yeah yeah we i feel like html parsers are really taking a beating
this week yeah um so the next one that's on the list and i i linked a youtube video in the notes like
genius um but this is this is uh the youtube video is live overflows um summary and we'll link this in
the description of course is live overflows um summary of some research that he he did based off
a weird tweet he saw and i've actually seen him do this a couple times where he like sees some weird
tweet and he's like oh that's kind of odd i bet that has security implications and then he like
creates a video of him like sussing that out and i think that's gold right like if anybody is trying
to you know this isn't a particularly beginners oriented podcast but if there are you know beginners
out there trying to learn how to you know up your research game that is a great example of of what to
do and what the pros do when when trying to you know uh conduct some security research so definitely
check out live overflows video in this one he's talking about a tweet that he saw where it said
there's something weird about the um less than and then number uh tags right because numbers aren't
valid html tags and somehow um the first so if you have an open tag it gets html encoded because it's not
a valid thing but if you have a close tag it gets stuck inside of a comment right so it's like yeah
this is kind of weird um so he kind of goes through there and comes up with this way to like
this this theory that he's got that this is going to bypass a bunch of html sanitizers and then he
goes and puts them in the html sanitizers and nah you know people have known about this for a long time
but it was a really cool exercise in how to research some quirky behavior so i figured i'd give
it a shout out anyway yeah yeah and lupin uh had a follow-up about you know about this this weird
behavior um and they were talking about in a video that this might be an interesting way to bypass a
waf and then somebody had left a comment linking to the source code in the chromium engine like where
this parsing actually happens and like what what it's looking for in terms of like a comment tag
and it was super super interesting to see you know the kind of quirks that you can do because of
this sort of edge case behavior where it's like a closing tag with a number in it that gets then
converted into something else yeah yeah for sure man i love that you know those people in the youtube
comments that read the chromium source code they the real mvps man like that's the real
shit yeah just leaving that in a youtube comment instead of like tweeting it or something it's got
one like you know it's crazy legendary like what an absolute legend right um so yeah like you said
really awesome stuff there i actually double clicked into the uh the google chromium um source code
and yeah it was really cool about and this is the comment specifically was it wasn't about the um
the numbers like i was talking about before this is about the question mark um and so if you put a
question mark in so you do less than sign question mark right this is no html encoding here this is just raw
you know no entities or anything um then that actually gets converted into a comment which i thought was
really interesting um and i in a little bit later in the episode today if we don't talk our you know
talk to the end of the episode about new stuff i'm going to talk about um some other cool ways to do job
comments in javascript but um this is a really interesting one that uh kind of like i didn't i didn't
realize you could trigger an html comment this way um and you know who knows when this stuff is going to be
useful maybe there's a scenario and you really need to comment something out and uh and you can't do it
uh because you know the stuff is sanitized or maybe like you can't put a maybe it needs to be like url
oh this is actually a viable scenario um like if you have like for some reason it doesn't want you to
have a uh bang in the url i've seen that before and uh but you can have the question mark so that could
be a cool way to smuggle in a html comment without um without using the bang yeah and we also showed
like you know with this other xss vector that just came out like you can do some weird stuff with an
html comment like in the tag as like part of the id or part of the attribute right so you could
potentially combine all these things together and chain it into one crazy bug that uh bypasses a lot of
wafts or bypasses everything yeah bypasses everything yeah even the html parser yes the html parser is
like what i can sense a dom purify bypass coming yeah it's it's like right on yeah next week or something
it's funny dude the the live overflow video he he's like ah you know i'm gonna go straight for the
for the super boss dom purify right and i'm here i was like nope nope yeah ben there done that yeah
exactly yeah no that that piece of software is pretty freaking solid it would be it would be really
cool to get a bypass in that though yeah so i don't know if you saw um mr tux racer he uh he had
tweeted out going on the next thing uh yeah mr tux racer had tweeted out uh a couple days ago i think
he said you know would there be any interest in a blog post about patch diffing i've been doing a lot
of patch diffing lately and it seems like something that might be an interesting topic like let me know
and so people replied and said yeah yeah for sure and yesterday uh he published a post on his blog
rcesecurity.com that goes into how he patched diffed a cbe in woocommerce and actually exploited it on a
target um and so this i think is a great case study about sort of how to approach these types of things
patch diffing is like a great way to find sort of hidden attack surfaces those like end day one day
two day type vulnerabilities that exist maybe they've been talked about in like release notes or
something but you haven't ever seen a public blog detailing and what the actual vulnerability is or
there's no poc and again this is like a great way to get that edge against like the other hackers
especially if you're a full-time hacker uh or you're just looking for some new attack surface
keeping your finger on the pulse like now anytime you see woocommerce you're gonna be like
hang on a sec i there's there's a bug for that um i'm not sure how exactly he found initially the like
the post i guess there was just a security advisor he said he mark like just mentioned like that there
was a uh there he noticed there was a uh an advisory published on word fence for this uh this bypass and
if you look it up it's got the cbe is like a 9.8 critical so i think that would probably catch
most people's attention woocommerce i think is also pretty pretty common it's pretty widely used yeah yeah
um so he went he got the source he diffed it against the old version sure enough figured out how to
exploit it and it's it's crazy it's just like one header right so simple dude x wc pay platform checkout
user equals one and uh with that header you can create new users and set them as an admin and just
escalate immediately to to wordpress account admin it's uh it's super super wild dude yeah i i read this
blog post and i was like you know i know that i know that julian um does a decent amount of like
wordpress related stuff which i think is cool because not a lot of people do because uh i don't know
i i don't i really honestly don't know why people don't go after it more core wordpress core is really
solid like if you can buy a bug in wordpress core you're pretty much you know you're set because that's
like 70 percent of the internet or whatever but um the plugins are pretty whack um and you can
enumerate the plugins um really easily um so yeah it's uh there's a lot of scope there um if you're
willing to do some source code review and this one you can see just how well this paid off um yeah
just a real i mean and and this is a good case study as well of like how patch shipping doesn't
have to be super mega hard like i mean he literally just dipped it and he was like there's like three
things different about this specific commit and uh and then you know he dives in and it's literally
just like add a header and it just destroys everything yeah um yeah i think for me like what
a lot of the reasons why i've like not exploited something on wordpress is there's like two main
reasons one is that it's really hard to get the plugin source code without paying for it or like
doing some jumping through a lot of hoops to like get your hands on the actual plugin which we talked
about it like pay for stuff you'll get an advantage generally speaking but that can also be risky
depending on how much the plugin costs the other side of it is that there's a really common wordpress
plugin like scanner thing uh tool i can't i can't remember like yeah wp scan yep and that generally just
looks for like public vulnerabilities that are like it are known to be exploitable and so if it's not
showing up in there then you may not know to even look for it and you may not dive any deeper than that
you might just see oh it's got these plugins okay move on and so going that extra step and getting your
hands on the plugin code patching patch diffing it against a known vulnerability or something like that
yeah and then exploiting it you know it it takes a little bit of extra effort but i think it's generally going to be worth it
yeah so so i i think that the piece about the getting your hands on the plugin code that can be true
if it's a pay-to-play plugin but like in my i've actually had a lot of luck with just going to work
you know wordpress.org plugins and finding the plugin and then just pressing the download button
downloading as a zip and you get the source code right um and i think i think um i'm not sure
if he did it this way in the actual yeah it looks like he actually dipped it inside of like
his own local machine or whatever so you could go and download the various older versions of it and then
dip it but sometimes they even have like github repos with the full source in there and various you know
commits and stuff like that which would make it even much easier so yeah i think i think um if anybody
really wants to try to do some um source code review related stuff it would be really cool to kind of go
to uh just go and look at the top wordpress plugin maybe like scroll down like three or four pages right
like get to get to the ones that are not like the mega mega wordpress plugins but like the semi-mega
you know popular wordpress plugins and then just do a security assessment of those and if you can pop
one that's got you know like this one has 600 000 plus active uh installations i'm sure you'll be
able to make some money off of that on above uh you know somewhere in bug bounty yeah and i believe
specifically this this was in woocommerce payments right so yeah so that's where it's like a little
weird right like if you look at the top commercial plugins on wordpress the third top commercial plugin
is woocommerce not woocommerce payments in the woocommerce woocommerce has five million active
installations over five million whereas woocommerce payments is 600 000 plus so it's just like little
things like that right like but i also think there's probably some really interesting research
if you were to do a deep dive source code review on all of those top plugins in general i am sure that
they're not all up buttoned up nicely and up to security spec there's there's gotta be some zero days
in there uh i i i can feel it for sure and actually that's a really cool pattern actually joel that you
mentioned is that's like a a supplemental plugin to a mega mega mega popular plugin right right so
woocommerce is like like you said top top five you know uh most popular yeah top three um and and so
you know maybe like a a plugin that sort of integrates with that or like you know connects up with
that that that could be a really good way to find a plugins that are a little bit less security tested
but also have a lot of widespread use right and the same sort of impact right like if you can find
like escalate from that secondary plugin into a main plugin because it's used as a dependency
that you know it's not it may not have the same amount of scrutiny and the same amount of security
checks and stuff like you said yeah no that's good stuff man good good good tips i might actually check
that out myself um okay dude we still got two more news we're almost through the days in our defense we
haven't done news in a little while because you know last episode was with cosmon so um yeah
oh and then the one before that was with uh was with rezo and and daniel so yeah yeah dude we haven't
done news in a while okay all right we're just catching up on some news yeah um i don't know if
we talked about this with the cbss4 yeah i don't know if we did we talk about it in person at the
we talked about it in person because uh ramsexy yeah uh noticed that in the cbss4 draft they had
made some changes i and i i recall this was while we were in london and i was like oh that's really
cool like ramsexy just like tweeted this out um so back june 21st ramsexy uh uh pierre luke uh
tweeted out that there were changes in the cbss4 draft spec and it said specifically under the
privileges required section that self-service provision accounts that may be necessary to
attack a cloud service do not constitute a privilege requirement if the attacker can grant themselves
permission these permissions as part of the attack and this feels fairly straightforward like this feels
logical like that feels like how it should be that feels like it shouldn't need explanation or need
to be explicitly written but if you look at how cbss3 is scored that is not the case oftentimes having
to create your own account does count as privileges required so like even though you could just go
self-register and give yourself these perms for some reason in cbss3 it gets graded as oh you need
privileges to do that instead of just being like a completely un-auth like you know which is like i
get it like that's that's the worst case scenario but when the when the worst like when when the next
step is having to walk through an open doorway like that's not i don't really count that as like
having to pick a lock you know what i mean it's like wow dude you just you just made like a pretty
good analogy on air on the fly amazing yeah yeah yeah i mean i don't know like maybe that's my own
weakness but like i just can't do analogies on the fly like that like you know that gets a that gets a
slow clap for you too thank you thank you thank you thank you i have a sleep still yeah no i mean like
dude you're killing it today i mean i couldn't even tell um but yeah no i i i agree and and it's kind
of a shame that cbss3 and 3.1 didn't address this a little bit earlier because it would have saved a
lot of bounty hunters a lot of money um but i was glad yeah exactly yeah um i was glad to see cbss4
did have that but here's the thing so go to that tweet click the quotes man
yeah a couple days ago yesterday um somebody somebody tweeted out so apparently and i actually went and i
checked this because i was like oh maybe it's just like a bug nope indeed they removed it at least in
the current draft spec for cbss4 they have removed that sentence from the privileges required uh section
it's just it disappeared like a week after ram sexy tweeted that out and uh who knows maybe maybe
somebody just like hit delete on the wrong commit i don't know i don't know it's um so i think it'll
be interesting to see what happens i know a lot of people are picking them on twitter being like what's
going on like why did they change this so i don't think they've they've actually said anything yet as to
what the reason was for removing that from the draft spec but i'm sure that
people will demand some sort of an answer so it'll be good to see yeah yeah i'd like to use the the power
of the critical thinking audience real quickly here like i'm gonna put we're gonna put this tweet um
by reef br in the in the description okay we need to go to this tweet and we need to
tag the freaking um first first.org you know twitter account and be like what the heck is going on
because this is gonna this is like taking money right out of our pockets here right and um and yeah
i would really like them to put that sentence back someone made a joke i think in the comments that was
like this is this is big bug bounty lobbying for like you know changes in this in the spec um uh but
yeah i would really like like an explanation at least um about why that decision was made uh and
hopefully we can get it reverted yeah yeah i'm about i'm actually quote tweeting them now go i'm
going what's up with this at first.org thinking emoji yeah we we absolutely need to do that so
we should i think i don't think that tweet even yeah so pierre luke's um tweet got like a bunch of
interaction uh on it like 230 likes or something like that and a bunch of retweets and then this other
guy like has only got like 22 likes or whatever and retweets yeah this is the one that needs to be like
smacked upon you know yeah 100 hopefully uh hopefully we get some clarification from purse.org
soon it's also really funny because like there are so many familiar names in the replies on the ram
sexy tweet just like celebrating the change yeah yeah and i don't i don't know how many of them have
realized that they they're getting bamboozled here yeah we need to go into that original thread
and like ping all the people and be like look at this look at this yeah yeah party man the last and final
news entry for today um is and we saved the best for last not gonna lie you know a tom nom nom tool
that's like mega bug bounty news right there yeah um yeah yeah so tom uh tom has not actually been
putting out a bunch of tools lately um but he drops this one on us which is which is great uh and i think
i think it's pronounced jace loose j s lease yeah jace loose jace loose yeah i do before this episode i went on online and like tried to find a video of someone talking about it so i could like i don't know i i i just i give up it's a tom nom nom actually tweeted about like the the way to pronounce this oh yeah yeah so let me find the exact tweet but i freaking love tom that he would do yes man so somebody
yes so so he tweeted out like that he had announced a new tool at bsides leads in the uk it's called
it's called j sluice um basically what it does is it takes in like a giant
string of javascripts and it will parse it out and it will do a bunch of heuristics and ast and that
kind of stuff to identify all the urls and paths and secrets within it and output that to you and
somebody actually replied and was like this is awesome but how do i pronounce the name and so he
replied to j dash sluice s-l-o-o-s-e j sluice so uh i think sluice is like uh like a term for some
that sluice is a an act of rinsing or showering with water i think i don't know this might be a uk term
or something because uh i was like familiar with it but yeah he commented under another one too and
he says it's named after sluice box a thing you use to find gold so i guess that's like the little
sifty thing that you use yeah when you're panning for gold yep nice nice cool solid that makes a lot
but yeah so the tool is really cool um it it does something which i think has been needed um in the
industry for a while which is it helps us to extract urls from js files and there are some really cool
tools out there i think the one i think link finder is it by um yeah dude i was trying to remember what
it was because it was actually crazy timing a couple days before this came out i was talking with somebody
in person at the at the live hacking event and i was like yeah isn't there some tool that like
parses the javascript and it pulls out the string constants and like looks for url paths or something
like that and this is basically exactly that but better um yeah so yeah for some context like for those
who don't know tom nom nom is like an incredible bug bounty hunter he was a bug bounty hunter for many
many years uh one of the ogs i would i would consider and uh it a couple years ago he left and he
started working at bishop fox as uh doing like security tooling and that kind of stuff yeah and
he's been a little bit quiet since then i'd imagine just because he's been uh you know building
cool cool stuff like this right and uh and yeah here we go this is an awesome awesome tool to see from
tom nom nom awesome to see uh that he's still doing you know that kind of like the security and the bug
bounty type stuff and this is going to be an awesome contribution to the bug bounty community because
this is such an amazing tool that's useful for parsing the javascript instead of having to
like dig through a million lines of obfuscated minified javascript you can just throw it through
j sluice and see what it outputs yeah absolutely yeah and so unlike link finder which is what i had
been currently using up until this point as well as just my own set of regex's this actually uses um
go tree sitter which is i guess a library which allows you to parse sort of syntaxical grammars a
little bit easier right and um and it uses that in order to parse out the whole js file and do a
little bit more intelligent matching on what sort of um so what sort of lines or what sort of variable
assignments and stuff like that are going to be resulting in a url being formed and then you know
passing that back to you with a little bit more information so um i really like that because it
does take that little bit out that i would have to do with a different tool of like going back to finding
the js source code and then reading it and being like oh you know uh it truncated this you know url
parameter that i really need or something like that um and it and it and it kind of makes it a little bit
more cohesive and put together which is really cool yeah yeah super cool i mean tom no mom is like an
amazing uh i mean his brain is just like great it's like yeah he's like 5x like what most people are
doing and so it's um i didn't even know what this this tree sitter was yeah but it's like uh it's a
syntax like tree part like a generic sort of like tree parsing tool and then the go trees tree sitter is
basically goling bindings on top of that and there are other language bindings as well so if you wanted
to write your own version of this in a different language like rust or something for example there
is a rust library that binds to tree sitter as well um so i think this is a super awesome to see this
kind of work in this space uh oftentimes so much of security research is just like regex instead of
actual parsing and like technical like low level type stuff so it's really really cool to see something like
like this come out and i think it's a great a great example case if you want to just like read through
the code and see how it works about how something like this you might be able to make a different
version of it or or another version of it yeah for sure all right man we made it we made it through
the news um just take a breath all right donate my brain again yeah right okay um so what i was hoping
to do today with the direction for the pod is just kind of go through a bunch of client-side related
stuff um yeah it's all client-side i think um that people i feel like people should know about that are
kind of at the fringe of stuff or or specifically stuff that i've learned at live hacking events
um just from other like really crazy good researchers um so uh let's let's kind of hit
this list the first one actually we talked about this a little bit before um personally but uh there's
this function in javascript called import right and this allows you to import um
um well essentially it's a it's a module import functionality for uh ecma script and it it kind
of blows the mind how it actually works in the browser because i didn't really think that would
yeah well yeah i remember when you first showed me this and i was like are you sure that this were
like i i had i had you actually walk me through like showing me that it was actually functioning in
the browser because i was 100 sure this was a node.js thing and that this was not going to be possible
and just like standard javascript within the browser and it it works i mean it's so weird it's the
strangest functionality that i've seen like it's extremely counterintuitive because you would
expect that this type of stuff just wouldn't exist in standard javascript for security reasons
uh and yet it does yeah i feel like but i learned about this originally from file descriptor
because whenever like i met file descriptor at a live hacking event a long time ago and uh and
whenever i had like a weird javascript situation i would just be like i would just ping him and we'd
get on a call and he'd like figure it out for me and i was like oh this is great so i saw him use this
once when we were talking about code golf right like how to minimize the amount of code that you have
and accomplish a goal and he used this to like import from an external you know uh script and i was like
oh this is pretty sick um yeah and yeah it saved my butt a couple times because a lot of times you
you know even if you can get an alert to pop if you have a um sort of a length limit on uh your your
input for an xss it's not actually possible for you to get um or i guess i won't say it's not
possible let me let me let me retract that statement because it's been proven time and time again that
you can do a lot of crazy stuff but um a lot of times you have you they you're asked to prove arbitrary
javascript execution um normally by importing a script or or show that you can execute long-form javascript
for an exploit right um yeah and this is a really cool tool for that um and so yeah i just wanted to
make sure the folks knew about this because i i think i kind of took this for granted working with
file descriptor and i think most of the people that i've showed it to have actually been like wait what
yeah yeah super crazy and also if if you actually go into the the mozilla uh docs the reference docs
about this the mdm web web docs that talk about this there's a specific warning that they call out
that says warning do not export a function called then from a module because this will cause the
module to behave differently when it's imported dynamically than when it's imported statically
and so i think this is a really interesting attack scenario where it's it's a bit of an edge case
but if you're able to do some sort of a file right or something like that where you can then get
to an import if the code say you have like some dynamic import that's importing from a file that
you can then control but it's calling dot then on it just like how with um deserialization bugs
where there's like a function that's going to be called implicitly just by how how it's functioning
you can hijack that by defining a then function in your module that's going to be exported and then
it'll run when it's imported on the site yeah no that that's that's really cool i didn't i i didn't
see that i didn't scroll down there to see that so that that's definitely another interesting attack
vector um but yeah no this is this is really sweet and it does allow my my xss payloads to get a little
shorter which i appreciate because it's actually not very trivial to get xss like for example if you
have if you have an image tag or an svg tag um xss it's not trivial to get a script imported in that
scenario because you can't just use script source right um that doesn't work after the dom has already
been loaded um and so yeah this is a cool tool for getting you there yeah yeah and i think it still
adheres to csp and stuff right like there's still there are still like limitations and stuff that that
it's not like just a complete like bypass of the security features but it's just another way to
basically get your javascript into the page yeah all right cool um next one was and this is one we've
talked about before but um gareth hayes's book javascript for hackers i i kind of took a read through
it and noted down some cool sections um and i just gonna was just gonna shout out a couple of these
let me pull up the book here um yeah okay so the first section that i thought was really interesting
was he he talks about how to um do how to the various different types of js comments that there are
and there are way more than i than i thought the particularly interesting one was that sort of a
legacy piece from before the browsers actually used um before they used javascript you know all the
browsers use javascript there was sort of a legacy implementation of where you can use an html comment
inside of javascript as a comment which i totally didn't know definitely didn't know about this and just
generally speaking this book is like an insane resource it's kind of the pinnacle of the kind
of stuff that we're talking about in terms of documenting strange behaviors yeah that you can
that aren't necessarily vulnerabilities by themselves but you can often tie these behaviors together to
exploit different scenarios easier or more effectively and it's twenty dollars on lean pub yeah so that's like
not even that's like a fraction of one xss that you could definitely get with this book
so uh definitely i would recommend investing in it and buying it and giving it a thorough read
and take some notes in your notes.txt file as an inhibitor would do
and uh and definitely take take some take some learnings from this because there's so many interesting
weird behaviors that the browser does to accommodate for like old old browsers or legacy behavior and that
kind of stuff to make stuff work across like new old stuff work in new browsers that you can then
exploit to your advantage yeah for sure and and so i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you scroll to page 66 in the in
the um in the book um and then he also mentions so there's there's four types of comments he mentions
in here and i'm not gonna you know i'm not gonna read them all read them all out because uh you know i
want you guys got to go buy the book but the the last one there number four in that list i i couldn't get
that one to work so i thought that one was a little bit interesting yeah i feel it i'm gonna double check
because that looks like it's a non-ascii character it could be i copied it but it i don't know i couldn't
get it to work but i will i will tell them about the first one on the list another um so i already
mentioned that you can use an html comment inside of js js but also there's another comment which is
hashtag bang which i did not know about um and that only he says the first example will only work if
it's the first javascript statement if it appears elsewhere a syntax error will be raised um and so i
i just didn't know about that and i think that's another really cool um edge case that you can use
to to comment some stuff out in the beginning of a of a javascript block yeah okay so yes i did check
that character it looks like a like a standard character it's actually a unicode character it's
the en dash so on mac it's like if you do option that it's like the long
like the long dash you know what i mean like uh sometimes it gets auto-corrected thing man
yeah like sometimes if you do a dash dash it'll get converted into an en dash where it's like
a lot it's like a long dash it's really more of a writing formality than anything yeah um but uh
yeah that's super super interesting i again i wonder if this is like backwards compatibility type
stuff where the two dashes it's like equivalent to the en dash and then yeah yeah nice yeah i i think
i think there might be that might have just gotten extended to a that should have might
should have been two dashes because that's the end of the oh yeah maybe that's a typo in the book
yeah and we said we weren't gonna mention it sorry sorry gareth now we're now we're just you know
but yeah apparently you know there's a way for you to actually comment out a whole line with the dash
with the you know closing html um comment um you know but yeah that that that seems a little bit
weird i'm gonna have to suss that out a little bit more i tried it before i it might have been it might be
something that the browsers have stopped implementing um as a as a security measure or not but um still a
couple really cool pieces in here um uh you know how to do how to smuggle in javascript comments
because those can be useful in javascript scenarios where you're injecting directly into a javascript
block and you've got to comment out the rest of the um the block yeah a little bit of a side tangent
here uh at the meta event so meta has this thing called hermes okay it's it's a javascript engine that
they wrote uh and it's super super interesting it's similar to v8 in in like what it does but uh there's
a whole community of researchers who only focus on testing and finding bugs in hermes just like how
there is for v8 as well how there's like you know chrome hackers or whatever like people who find
javascript engine bugs and it's the same thing for hermes and this type of weird syntax stuff makes me
wonder like where that parsing is actually happening within a javascript engine yeah and sort of like how
that functionality is working and whether or not you could actually pinpoint within the engine these types
of edge cases for how the how the engine is identifying a comment and like what qualifies as a comment and
then use that to your advantage to find either new exploit exploitation cases or other exploitation cases
that may not even be mentioned here yeah dude i i have endless respect for those people that just like
pick this one project or like this one focus and then just like just like into the ground you know like
that's it's it takes so much dedication and and you know the knowledge does compound though so it kind of
makes sense why they would want to keep that snowball rolling of knowledge for sure project and and while
you were talking about that actually did go back uh and you know i i was not able to reproduce that
before because it got normalized into the um uh the elongated uh dash like you said the en dash but
actually if you put two dashes like i think that's what it should be um that becomes the closing html
comment and that actually does work as a comment in javascript so okay we might have to tell gareth
because he'll update his book he has a little typo in there from he probably typed it on on a mac or
something and it yeah it got autocorrected well you know these are just the secrets you get for
listening to critical thinking podcast you know even even garrett's book we're hacking it yeah now you
know um all right so next one was okay dude this one's actually really interesting um this is another
one that i just kind of took for granted i think just because of like something i saw early on in my
bug bounty experience but um this is regarding a specific context where you are injecting into
oftentimes what it ends up being is a javascript variable okay so you know you're inside a script
tag you're in a javascript variable and your input is going inside of that variable right now that
variable is being defined with either single or double quotes per javascript there could be a
templating string as well but that's rare um and uh if you're inside that um you know you the initial
instinct would be to try to use double quotes or single quotes to escape that variable and get an xss
you know just by injecting javascript in there um and then you know the second sort of route if that
fails would be to try to do something funky with like backslashes right and escaping you know the end
of that um that double quote or the single quote and seeing if you can link it together with another
injection point to kind of get an xss um but another one that i feel like people miss a decent bit
is you have to still sanitize the html elements because yeah um because you know at the end of the day you're
inside of a script tag and the only way that the browser is going to know that that script tag is
going to end is like with an actual you know back you know less than slash script you know end tag
and so if you do that inside of the javascript context you it's going to just cut off the rest of
the javascript and then you have html injection and you can get xss from there so yeah i mean there's
nothing in the browser spec or anywhere that states that you have to have valid javascript in your
script tags right like you can have like an open quote that never ends right and then you just
close it with a script tag right and so in that same sense like if you have something that's being
injected directly into a string you don't have to end that string you could just close the script
tag and keep like put elements in the page yeah yeah and then you know get xss by a like you
know an on click or an on hover right and on the event handler which is going to have a different
different csp as well because the csp for script source is not the same as you know like including
other for example an import right like that's going to go to a different csp yeah that is a little bit
tricky though if you have a non-spaced uh script tag and that that script has a nonce on it right if you
close off that tag then you're not going to be able to smuggle your your you know payload inside of that
scripted nonce so see csp it's kind of a it's kind of a double-edged sword sometimes with that sort of
thing yeah yeah i wonder if maybe that could that that's something that we could talk about in the
future is uh there's the csp evaluator tool that that google made that's and that's pretty good um you
can basically just paste the csp in there we'll link it but you just paste like a csp uh full like
directive in there it'll tell you like if it's vulnerable to things they have a list of known uh
domains and like paths that have um what what is it the like js uh the callbacks basically the json p
endpoints i'm not i'm not sure what you're talking about yeah so google has the the csp uh
evaluator csp evaluator dot with google right and if you put a whole content security security policy
string in there it will check it and it'll tell you whether or not each part of it is safe and whether
or not there are certain bypasses so certain domains like youtube.com and stuff they have um
alert like poppable basically like gadgets that you can exploit that still will uh they'll still
adhere to the csp yeah you can use them to get an xss and i'm wondering if there's anything that goes
beyond that that does more of a deep dive in terms of like uh not necessarily a problem with the csp but
ways that you could work within the csp outside of like you know just oh this domain you could use this
domain as a gadget to then pop an xss maybe you could all you could also say oh you would have to
put something within a script tag in order to adhere to this nonce that's in the csp or something like
that dude and i don't think i've seen any tool like that csp is like a whole episode of its own
probably actually originally had it in this episode to talk about some stuff about csp and cores
and i was like uh you know especially after all the news we added there's just no way we're
going to get to any of that today yeah uh yeah so yeah and for what it's worth the csp evaluator is
based on research that was done in 2016 so it's been almost oh my god it's getting we're getting old
dude it's been almost 10 years oh my gosh so dude you know there's there's definitely been some bypasses
and stuff that are not going to be in that list um and some other like confounding factors that are
there that are not going to be in that list that are worth looking at so i don't think the csp value
evaluator is the sort of end-all be-all uh when you're looking at a csp and there are going to be
some other sort of knowledge things that you're going to want to keep in mind when you're looking at
a csp that won't get called out by the evaluator yeah yeah for sure and it like i feel like those
endpoints though like you were saying before the json pm points in particular like i've thought about
reporting endpoints where you can like for example you can smuggle in a um a semicolon or like a comma
or something that will allow you to actually inject um uh arbitrary js code into the callback
parameter for those json p endpoints and i totally feel like that's a bug especially for big companies
where it's like you know you're gonna you're going to have other people approving your site as a as a csp
you know bypass right as a as a uh as an allowed site within csp like you've got to use that that
power responsibly um right and you know make sure you're taking care of those um those json p endpoints
and there's just there's just a you know a lot of like you mentioned there's a lot of gadgets out there
that'll still allow you to just bypass it unfortunately and again i think this is one of those
those artifacts of like legacy support where they're now in a place where if they were to change
how that endpoint works for like a json pm endpoint then stuff that's using it in the past may break
because they're using it incorrectly and and so now it's like vulnerable by design but they can't fix it
yeah because they can't migrate people away from it because it's like hard-coded and yeah but who's
using a semicolon in their json back you know like nobody i've seen a lot of really sketchy
a lot of really sketchy engineer behaviors if they engineered it like that their site deserves to
break you know okay yeah it deserves to be a json p point at that point exactly um okay the last thing
i wanted to talk about from from garrett's book um is his notes on prototype uh pollution um which i
feel like was sort of a a bug that i just kind of thought was like researchy you know like it's everywhere
i've seen it i've seen it in like one live hacking event someone got like a crazy bug with it
um but another one you're talking about yeah and and i'm not gonna go down the the rabbit hole too
much of like trying to explain all of this on the pod today but um the section of this book it was
really interesting to me and actually helped me understand prototype pollution a lot more and
actually gave me some good hands-on tips for scanning for it and for how to identify it within a
you know an organization or within an application um and so i feel like this is one of the things where
it would be a lot of work because they're kind of hard to exploit even once you find them
but this could be something where you could set up a headless browser you could put this sort of
payload in the url that he mentions in the in the book and then um you know spam that across all of the
websites and all of the endpoints that you know about um you know through recon and uh and i think
that would probably kick out some pretty quality results yeah and for what it's worth in an addition
gareth works at port swigger um but the port swigger web academy web security academy has an awesome
section it's all about prototype pollution it goes into um both the like server side and the client side
aspects of like identifying what it is how it works um just like all the intricacies of like what prototype
pollution is and and what's going on underneath when you're when you're sending like an underscore
underscore proto underscore underscore in your payloads and i would encourage you to just read about it
because it's definitely one of those things that doesn't get looked at as much as it should and if you
think about or you just read just read some developer code and you'll realize how many places it's possible
to get prototype pollution just by writing javascript you don't have to be using like lodash
and stuff to get prototype pollution it definitely exists in normal developer patterns um and i think
it's a lot more common than people think it's just another one of those things that kind of like an xss you
need to kind of like spray it and see if it's going to pop anything kind of weird and it'll be pretty
noticeable if it's if it's behaving with prototype pollution um sort of sort of behavior there'll be
indicators for sure yeah and and the server side stuff as well like with node that's really interesting
as well i'm sure that's a lot you know trickier to actually exploit because you don't have the the source
code but i i've seen at least one server-side prototype pollution that just like yes it's amazing
yes in my own job experience i've seen one not at my current company but uh but at a previous place
i've seen a really bad server-side prototype pollution and it was like a systemic uh problem
because it was like a a common pattern that was being used in like a lot of different places and it
was just like uh honestly just like a a pitfall that the engineers thought that this was going to
be fine but it it wasn't and the the thing with prototype pollution right especially on the server side
is that you're you're polluting the object itself right so that means that every single object from
then on is going to be tainted which means that it has way widespread implications in terms of like
how it can be exploited and the things that it can do and it'll affect all parts of the application
not just one part of the application and so the impact can be insane if you get a server-side
prototype pollution yeah and and i imagine that could even cause dos as well depending on how the
the the server side deals with all of those you know objects that are sort of corrupted via the
by corrupting the prototype so yeah really cool stuff there um let's since we just mentioned port
swigger academy let's jump down to the dom clobbering uh section this is another really cool
interesting sort of fringe bug type that i really actually i was gonna talk to you guys you know
talk to you guys about it on the pod and then i was like oh wait actually like i feel like i don't
actually fully understand how this gets exploit exploited and like i clicked on the port swigger academy
link for this which we'll put in the description and there's just a beautiful example joel look at
this code i don't know if you got a chance to review this but look at this code like i totally did not see
the way that you could exploit this um and so essentially what they've got going on here is that
they're accessing a an arbitrary you know window object so window dot some object and they're accessing
an attribute of that object some object.url and they're setting that as the source for a for a script
tag right it actually doesn't seem like that far out there of a uh of a of a code pattern right and it's
it's saying if with just html injection above this above the script you can hijack this in in get xss on
the page and it does this via injecting a two a tags um one that has the id some object and another one
that has the id sub object and then but the second one also has the name url and an href and what ends up
happening here i did break it down in my browser um when the the a those two a objects both have the same id
they get sort of clustered into um a dom collection and that dom collection uh allows you to when you
when they try to access it by a window dot some object that some object id the id for that dom
collection gets put into that you know window it gets defined at the window level within the application
so now you've kind of snagged access to that variable and then the piece that i didn't know
about is you could define sub attributes for that object yeah with the name yeah i knew you could you
know hijack essentially a variable in the window with dom clobbering that's like traditional dom
clobbering that i would think about um but then you not only can you do that but you can also add
snag sub attributes of that um using this using the the dom collection and then the name
attribute um inside the second element and then so it then selects that second a tag right um when it
when you use some object dot url and then it abuses the a tags dot two string when when you do two
string on an a tag it takes the it returns the href yeah yeah exactly i mean it's like amazing again
these are like the the like the edge case like weird stuff that you kind of wouldn't necessarily know
about or even expect right like the fact that you can access any element by its id off the window
object yeah it's like already uncommon like just like it's super counterintuitive behavior that that
that would be a thing because it seems fairly arbitrary that just like defining an id would make
it accessible on the window normally you'd expect to have to do like document dot query selector or
something like that and the fact that it just implicitly does that already opens up a lot of windows for
opportunity for exploitation that you may not have expected originally where you you can now oh if i
can just insert an html element or if i can put something you know you in the url on an html element
that i don't necessarily i can't escape out of it but i can control what's in the href value or something
right well now you can exploit that potentially depending on how it's being used and those types of
edge cases are really important to know yeah it's just it's just amazing to me how they combined the
the two-string you know manipulation the dom collection thing with when you have multiple ids
with the same or multiple tags with the same id and then this whole weird window window dot whatever
the id is functionality here to actually trigger a a very exploitable scenario in dom clobbering i kind
of thought dot clobbering was like mostly used for like sandbox escapes and like weird stuff like that
um but yeah it actually seems like it has some very real xss uh implementations yeah super super
strange behavior all righty man we are at i guess an hour 17 here oh man where do we where do we want
to go because we got a bunch of stuff left we have to talk about but we could push some of this to the
to a different episode yeah um do you want to let um i'll leave it up to you i think we could talk
about these last couple things the meta tags and stuff or we can uh we can save it for another episode
yeah you are start looking like you're you're going downhill just a little bit um i started out strong
my jet fuel's running out yeah yeah so let's let's we'll we'll hit the meta and base tags and then we'll
we'll call it a wrap for this time around and maybe we'll do another episode on like weird browser
quirks because there's a lot of other stuff that we had in the doc here that i think the people need
to know about um but yeah so the other thing that i kind of want to mention and this was actually
sparked by a bug at a live hacking event which you probably know the one that i'm talking about
but a friend of ours used a meta tag to get a really really crazy bug at a live hacking event
because he had an html injection um and uh and so this is something that i just kind of wanted to
make sure everyone was aware of because whenever you have html injection it's it feels kind of bad
you know if you can't get it to to xss but depending on the context there's still a lot you can do
um and meta and base tags are two of the primary tags that you can use to to really do something cool
with yeah um i mean this cheat sheet is awesome there's a ton of cheat sheets out there but i think
you know uh keep some of your own notes i think is like the the key i would say because like otherwise
you're gonna have a folder that's got 50 different cheat sheets that are bookmarked in it and when
you're trying to think of that one thing you're gonna have to click through all of them to find them
um yeah but yeah this is really really interesting i didn't actually um i don't really fiddle with
meta tags very much and i think it's kind of underrated i like early on like way back in the
day like meta tags used to be like a much easier exploit scenario where you could just like set
like base urls or something like that that would allow you to exploit them i don't know how much
that's still possible yeah so some of the functionality because you used to be able to i
think trigger xss via um via a meta tag and right um according to this cheat sheet it's still
possible using a data uri this was not something i got to test before um the episode it says here that
it only works in safari so i can't test it right now joel if you i don't know if you second most
popular browser yeah exactly seriously if you've got your you know i don't know if you're on your mac
right now but if you want to just throw that little um you know data scheme into the into safari and see
if it works then go for it but um but meta essentially has a bunch of functionality and one of the
cool attributes of it is this http equiv attribute and originally it was designed to allow you to
essentially set http headers inside of the the page like sort of i guess sort of retroactively because
it's like you've already loaded the body of the request um and i feel like there's a lot more potential
for that um you know then then is possible right now but um if you if you look at this let's see if
i can pull up this uh picture that i had in the in the doc the current values that are accessible for
that are content security policy content type default style and refresh and each one of those are all
like pretty freaking interesting i think um because with content security policy you can trigger a content
security policy to execute um inside the browser using using that meta tag we see that pretty often
that's that's pretty common um but setting the content type this includes encoding that that's another
thing that i hadn't really thought about before researching for this episode is like you may be able to
to use the meta tag to change the encoding for the content body and trigger some xss further down in
the page um if you've got some weird injection points so that's one that i hadn't really thought about
yeah so i just tested this on on safari um let's see what version the latest of our version 16.5.1
and what it does it throws an error so i don't know if it's actually exploitable or maybe you might
need to do some modifications but it does say not allowed to navigate top frame to data url data colon
text html so it does like it's parsing it and it's like skipping over that zero uh zero semicolon thing
yeah uh and it does seem to like try to do it but maybe this is something that they added recently
um as as a fix um because i know that like some of the things that are in this cheat sheet are
definitely for older versions like it talks about like from 65 which is probably that's way out there
five five plus years old yeah yeah for sure and so like it said there used to be a set cookie
instruction which is like oh my gosh that would be lit the good old days that's so fun but the way
that i see meta tags used most most um commonly now for exploitation purposes is for this content
security policy stuff and then also primarily for this redirection um piece right because like think
about it it's very hard to get actually i can't even really think of another way
to x to redirect a page with no user interaction with with just html without using javascript right
yeah and for what it's worth that's that works on safari at least so i just tested that like the the
meta redirect for the language tag like that works totally fine yeah but redirecting it to a data url it
doesn't want to do yeah so you've definitely got that in your pocket and this can be useful in a bunch of
different scenarios um it can be useful on embedded devices it can be useful um in inside of headless
browsers um and so uh the open redirect piece you know by the meta tag is really cool and i would love
to see some research surrounding um the content type piece um because i feel like there's definitely some
interesting functionality there i was trying to think about the default style piece um i i couldn't
really come up with anything but it seems weird to me so yeah so i mean there's always the the scenario
that always comes to mind with like style stuff for me is the key like the key press uh like sniffing
where i think that's always been like a really solid attack scenario where if you can eject styles like you
you can either you can create a really plausible phishing scenario because you're on an ssl signed
website that's looks completely different and might have different different content and stuff
but you can also do like key like key input like changes where you like hit a background like a
background url or something and i think it still goes through some sort of csp right um but you know
depending on the scenario you can sniff keybinds within the website purely through css yeah which is
just like insane yeah i love i love that bug so much there's been some really cool stuff with that
and i'm actually i'm looking at because like w3 schools is a great resource and i i use them all the
time for yeah for for you know this sort of thing but oh yeah there's also well i'm not i'm just
thinking about it right freaking out oh okay oh you good can you hear me yeah i'm back sorry it like
totally went crazy for just a second okay cool um yeah so i i was just thinking about this right now
like as we were talking about css a couple years ago there was a pro a project that came out called doom
nukem css and it's a full implementation of doom that's written in html and css no way and maybe it
uses typescript too i don't actually i don't actually know but i'm pretty if i recall correctly
i could have sworn it was like all css which is like the craziest thing but it looks like there's a
decent amount of typescript in here i might be wrong well you know gareth hayes you know we mentioned
him a couple times on this um on this episode his personal website if you go to his twitter profile
and you click his bio link that's like a css based like freaking interactive game masterpiece of a
website and it's just kind of like an ongoing project for him and i'm like wow that's like such
a cool hobbyist activity of like just mastering css stuff and he and he tweets about like css related
quirks all the time which i think is really helpful as well yeah what is it gareth hayes.co.uk
yeah check it out yeah oh man this is while you're checking out no this is exactly what i was
thinking of actually yeah yeah so there's some really crazy stuff you can do with css um with just
pure css which is nuts but um i what i was going to say before my computer started losing its mind
um was that i went to w3 schools and i was it says that there's only four attributes that can go
inside of or values that can go inside of the http equiv um header or i mean html attribute um but
actually i'm looking at some other stuff and i think there's more so like i've seen other references
to window.target and content encoding as well so i'm actually after this episode i'm going to go try to
suss that out because um i think there might be some other things we can put in http equiv that could
really really really mess with the you know the dom um that's being loaded up so definitely some cool
stuff i also wonder if there's like undocumented features and still like functionality because i
feel like a lot of browsers will create just like they'll create weird edge cases with like that they
use internally um that are only really designed to be used by them that may not adhere directly to
the html spec or what the public spec says should be possible but is actually still possible and you
know it's important to remember that just because the spec says that it should be this way doesn't mean
that it's actually implemented that way for sure yeah yeah there's definitely some some i'm looking
through right now there's some weird some weird stuff there so i'm going to check that out afterwards
um but for for those of you listening right now what we can what we can confirm right here is it's it is
helpful for exploitation in a content security policy scenario if you want to make the content security
policy stricter to lock out like for example a um like for example if they're loading up a js library
that does purification or something like that then it's helpful there and then it's also possible
to use it for a a no additional click or redirect if you have an html injection so that's helpful as
well yeah yeah super cool um so the other thing that we were going to talk about here was the base tags
um and base tags this is something that that i didn't know about till recently i think these have
to be in inside the head um uh sort of section within the browser um or within the dom so i'm not sure
how often we're getting injections up in there um but yeah there's some really cool stuff you can do with
this um essentially it allows you to turn relative urls into uh you know fully qualified urls with your
domain which is super helpful for um you know hijacking stuff further down in the flow of the page
uh and and maybe even bypassing csp in some scenarios um yeah some i don't know if you can nonce an
external import but um yeah that would be that would be helpful in that scenario yeah i'm just testing this
one on safari as well just to double check because i'm pretty sure you're right that it has to be
almost certain it has to be in the in the head yeah yeah i think i think it has to be um uh but
yeah i i didn't know about this and this is just another really cool piece that you can you can use
an html injection it doesn't it doesn't have to be in the head what maybe safari's doing something weird
yeah this could be something that's far too doing weird but i did just double check and in my body
element i put a base href and a script tag and it is trying to load it from the base url wow that's in
the body tag that i stand corrected man yeah this this has a lot of power this element um and html like we
mentioned html injections can be kind of tricky but this is definitely something that you can use to
kind of try to turn the tides in your favor headers chrome is doing it too i've nerd sniped joel is just
like staring wide-eyed at his at his computer right now like chrome does it too so yeah if you put the
base tag even in the body up yeah dude i i could have sworn that it was a head only thing yeah but okay
yeah so a base uh base tag anywhere um will change where it tries to load from even if it's in the body
very solid man yeah i think that's all i've got for base base stuff um dude we skipped over so much
we have a whole second episode worth of content that we didn't even talk about we've already prepped
for another episode i'm just going to copy this over into the other doc because this is yeah a lot of
stuff but anything else you want to add before we wrap this one up oh no i think that was it i love
how this is like one of our longest episodes and it was like on a on a us holiday and after you drove
you know just flew back from korea so yeah yeah another another banger but yeah no thank you for
putting together all these links because there's no way i would have been able to find all this stuff
and um i've got some notes i need to take now i think just for my own personal personal stuff i'm
just gonna say good luck to our producer trying to fit all this in the episode description there's like
50 bajillion links but all right cool that's a wrap awesome all right yeah catch you later sweet peace
so we after the episode ended we just went and kind of tried to suss out that base thing
a little bit more about the uh you know being able to put the base tag in the body and i swear
that was not something that used to be the case yeah but it it says specifically in the html spec that it
has to be in the head head tag inside the head tag and it works perfectly fine in the body tag in lots of
browsers so i've never seen this documented before and i think this has some pretty bad xss implications
yeah i mean uh we're looking at the html spec directly and it says that the context in which a
base element can be used is within a head element containing no other base elements and if you put
a base element in a body it works it still works uh the only real caveat that i've seen through the
limited testing that we just did is that if there's a base element in the head already the one in the
body will not override it which is expected but it shouldn't be possible that you put one in the body and
it works it should completely ignore it unless it's in the head uh which is super wild because that you
can inject those so yeah yeah we got to do more live testing on the pod just like this all right
cool all right that's a wrap yeah yeah catch you catch you the next week
all righty after that data-packed episode i have one measly request for you at the end of this episode
and that is for you to head over to ctbb.show and subscribe to our newsletter we're trying
to grow the content over there jesse rivera is putting out some awesome blog cast summaries
of the episodes you don't want to miss out on those so yeah ctbb.show head over there subscribe thanks